Viserys Targaryen: For three hundred years
the Targaryen dynasty stayed strong, in the
face of rebellion, civil war, and plague.
But the line of dragon kings was broken when
my father, Aerys Targaryen, the Second of
His Name, was overthrown in rebellion.
My father was betrayed and slaughtered by
Ser Jaime Lannister, a member of his own Kingsguard.
His son and heir, my brother Rhaegar, perished
on the field of battle at the hands of Robert
Baratheon, who claimed the Iron Throne for
himself.
Robert Baratheon: "Ours is the Fury."
These are the words of the black stag of Baratheon.
A battle cry echoed throughout the land in
rebellion, when I, Robert Baratheon, the First
of His Name, seized the Iron Throne from the
Mad King, Aerys Targaryen, ending a dynasty
nearly three hundred years old.
After Aegon's conquest of the Seven Kingdoms,
the Baratheons remained loyal enough to the
crown while Targaryen kings came and went.
But loyalty has its limits.
When Rhaegar Targaryen, Aerys' vile son and
heir, abducted Lyanna Stark, my betrothed,
my beloved, it was time to act.
We raised our banners.
Baratheon, Stark, Jon Arryn, and the Tullys,
united in rebellion against Rhaegar and his
father, the Mad King.
We were victorious and took the Iron Throne.
That bit of dragon blood in my veins came
in well as it made me a distant relation to
the Targaryen dynasty blood of my long-lost
ancestor, Orys.
The truth of it is I took it.
Brynden Tully: Under the Targaryens, the Riverlands
knew a peace we hadn't had for centuries,
if ever.
But like all good things, sooner or later,
it all goes to shit.
And our shit had a name.
Aerys Targaryen.
Westeros has had its share of Mad Kings, but
usually, they had the sense not to bully more
than one powerful house at a time.
Aerys soon blundered into a triple alliance.
The North, Stormlands, and Vale rose against
him.
But of course, where do you think most of
the blood was spilled?
My brother Hoster guaranteed the answer to
that with the marriage of my niece to Eddard
Stark, the Warden of the North.
At least Hoster didn't send her to Robert.
So, the Riverlands joined the war against
the Mad King; and it was on one of our rivers
that Prince Rhaegar died, sealing the fate
of his dynasty.
Robert was a great soldier and a horrible
king.
Catelyn Stark: Whatever the case, House Frey
does nothing so well as survive.
When the ironborn conquered and razed the
Riverlands, the Freys hid in their castle.
When Aegon and House Tully swept the ironborn
back to their islands, the Freys hid in their
castle.
When my ancestor demanded their allegiance
as Aegon's new Lord Paramount of the Trident,
the Freys bent the knee from their castle.
Perhaps then we should not have been surprised
when my father, Lord Hoster Tully, called
his banners against the Mad King and Lord
Walder didn't answer.
The Baratheons, Starks, Arryns, and Tullys,
some of the oldest and greatest houses of
Westeros, fought and bled for the cause of
justice while House Frey hid in its castle
and waited.
No doubt if Rhaegar had won at the Trident,
Lord Walder would have given him safe passage
into the North to destroy the rest of my husband's
Northern army for a fair price.
But Rhaegar fell and, lo and behold, the Frey
army appeared to render aid to our already
victorious forces.
Many sniggered that Lord Walder had been waiting
for his army to come of age, having fielded
it out of his own breeches.
My own father named him The Late Lord Frey
to the other lords' amusement.
In many ways, however, Lord Walder was wise.
We had no guarantee of victory and had he
fought with us from the outset and we failed,
he would have lost the bridge his family was
so proud of.
"More Pride Than Honor."
those should be the words of House Frey.
Yet part of me wonders if Lord Walder waited
not out of fear but hope.
That we would be destroyed, leaving him to
assume my family's place as Lord Paramount
of the Trident.
To buy the respect they have always wanted,
but refused to earn.
Brienne of Tarth: Targaryen rule quieted the
Stormlands for the most part until Robert
rebelled against the Mad King.
His first challenge came not from the Crown,
but from his own bannermen who tried to join
forces against him.
Robert struck first, defeating three armies
in a single day at Summerhall.
The victory cemented Robert's control of the
Stormlands, and he was able to march on the
Reach and Riverlands with no enemy to his
rear.
Yet not all of Robert's bannermen sided with
him.
Ser Barristan the Bold came from the Stormlands,
but as the preeminent member of Aerys's kingsguard
and greatest knight in the realm, Ser Barristan
remained loyal.
After Robert's decisive victory on the Trident,
Robert sent his own maester to care for his
countryman Ser Barristan, who had suffered
grievous wounds while fighting so hard to
kill him.
Later, when the Kingslayer betrayed Aerys,
Robert pardoned Ser Barristan and even took
him onto his own kingsguard.
Catelyn Stark: House Arryn remained loyal
to the Targaryen dynasty.
Until Lord Jon Arryn joined with Houses Baratheon
and Stark in rebellion against Mad King Aerys.
Upon winning the Iron Throne, Robert named
Lord Jon Hand of the King, a position he held
until his mysterious death.
Littlefinger: The Vale's isolation does breed
an abundance of honor and pious bleating,
which governs their decisions instead of foresight.
Like a blind man who can only guess where
his horse is taking him, I doubt Jon Arryn
had even prepared for civil war when he raised
his banners instead of handing over his young
wards, Ned Stark and Robert Baratheon, to
the Mad King.
Honor demanded, and Lord Arryn obeyed.
He'd have done the same if the boys hadn't
been the lords of two great houses, who could
field mighty armies of their own.
But perhaps I give him too little credit.
After all, if the war went against them, only
Lord Arryn had a nice impregnable castle to
retreat into; and he was wise enough to take
poor Lysa Tully into his bed to win the Riverlands
as allies.
Jon Arryn won, then Jon Arryn died.
Margaery Tyrell: The Reach stayed loyal.
Mostly.
My father, Mace, dealt Robert his only defeat
in the war, even if it was my father's vanguard
who did most of the fighting before he arrived.
After the Battle of Ashford, we laid siege
to Storm's End, Robert's home.
Unfortunately, the war ended before we could
take it and free up our armies to go save
the king.
Some may question my father for laying siege
to the Baratheon's home instead of marching
to aid Prince Rhaegar before Robert could
kill him and scatter the royal army.
But let us not forget that we had already
dealt Robert his only defeat of the war at
Ashford.
If Lord Tywin Lannister had not "vanquished"
the Mad King so suddenly, our siege would've
destroyed Robert's home and his brothers and
won the war for Aerys.
But when the Targaryens fell, House Tyrell
again chose peace and prosperity over war
and devastation, and bent the knee to King
Robert Baratheon, First of His Name.
Jaime Lannister: I remember the day the Lord
Commander wrote my name down in the White
Book, the official record of the Kingsguard.
At sixteen, the youngest member ever to join,
knighted by Ser Arthur and Ser Barristan for
valor against the Kingswood Brotherhood.
An outlaw had decided to try his luck against
a lowly squire.
He was not using his head, so I took it off
him.
Shortly afterwards, King Aerys the Second,
who hadn't yet earned the title of the Mad
King, took me into his service.
If I have ever been happy, it was that day.
Everyone in his kingdoms soon knew the names
and sang the songs of the Kingsguard.
I certainly did from earliest days.
Lord Commander Gerold Hightower, the White
Bull; Arthur Dayne, the Sword of the Morning.
Bronn: Arthur Dayne, Gerold Hightower.
Sure, if half the stories about them are true,
they could swing a sword better than most.
Makes their lives even more of a waste.
Bodyguards to the maddest king the Seven Kingdoms
ever saw.
Watching their king burn men alive.
Hiding the Stark girl that Prince Rhaegar
stole away, causing a war that toppled their
king.
And all this without any gold or women to
show for it.
Stupid buggers!
The only one with any sense was Jaime Lannister.
When his father stormed the city, he put a
sword through the Mad King's back rather than
die gloriously at his post.
He's still here.
They are not.
Oberyn Martell: My sister, Elia.
She married Prince Rhaegar Targaryen and became
the Princess she already was.
In Dorne, she walked among vipers, and none
would bite her.
In King's Landing, she found herself surrounded
by lions.
When Robert Baratheon rebelled against his
rightful king, his future father-in-law, Tywin
Lannister, ordered his beast Gregor Clegane
to murder my sister along with her helpless
children.
And men call the Lannisters "heroes."
Hallyne: Dragons conquered the Seven Kingdoms.
But to rule them, the Targaryens needed a
less temperamental tool.
When the great King Maegor saw the power of
the Alchemists' Guild, he blessed us with
his patronage.
In those days, we commonly transmuted metals
and other wonders, but the King was most interested
in our mastery of the Substance, which those
not of our order dub "wild-fire."
After the unfortunate Prince Aerion Targaryen,
drunk with wine, boasted that a draft of the
Substance would transmute him into a dragon,
we lost our royal favor.
Then came the wise King Aerys, Second of His
Name.
I was merely an acolyte when he restored our
Guild to its former glory.
As had his great forefathers, he appreciated
our secret arts, even naming Wisdom Rossart
as Hand of the King.
Together, they punished his enemies as befits
a true Targaryen.
During the War of the Usurper, I heard whispers
that King Aerys had engaged our greatest Wisdoms
for an ultimate weapon against his foe.
But, sadly, King's Landing must have fallen
before it could be used, and many of our Wisdoms
disappeared in the sack of the city.
Victims of ignorance and envy as ever, I'd
wager.
Littlefinger: The realm had no sharper minds
than Lord Tywin Lannister, Hand to King Aerys
Targaryen, or as history remembers him, "The
Mad King."
He saw assassins and plots in every shadow,
heard whispers in silence, and burned men
alive, but his greatest madness by far was
driving away Lord Tywin.
The Mad King then cycled through every mistake
of his ancestors.
Soldiers, toadying lords and at the end, even
an alchemist, perhaps to save the crown's
growing expenses on wildfire.
Unfortunately, it didn't save his crown or
his dynasty.